i just wanted to change the scenery
and i'm kind of in a weird spot with my
boyfriend
we shot the season out of order so we
shot the finale probably the third week
of filming so i think this is the first
time of really kind of putting all the
pieces together to really be like oh
this is the end of our senior year
together
the reason why they did not go with the
first name of college-ish is because the
show isn't confined to the world of
college and so i'm excited for
whatever's to come
next grownish is back for season four on
freeform the cast graduates and prepares
for adult life
what do you guys hope
the fans the fans take from grown-ish
what's the legacy you guys need i just
hope that when people watch this show
it's a sense of like relief to know that
growing pains are normal
you feel like you need to be successful
by the time you're 21 and it's not
really like that i just hope whoever
watches it they don't feel alone
and they feel
represented in some form or fashion
because you know like as you're saying
everyone is like at a different point in
their life and you just want to know
that it's okay to make mistakes like i
feel that
through the essence of our whole show i
mean it's been great to see us mess up
sometimes and then get it together and
figure it out and show the world that
it's okay
[Music]
of course chloe and hallie bailey have
done plenty of growing since singing the
show's theme song in 2018. beyonce's
proteges have earned five grammy
nominations both launch solo careers and
halley stars in the live-action remake
of the little mermaid due in may of next
year what's your big takeaway from this
show what did you learn i really learned
how to have more courage in myself
through sky her journey of kind of
finding
her power and moving forward in her
track career really grateful for
that experience of having to act that
out with my sister
because it gave me strength to do that
in real life it was also scary with the
last season without halle being there
because we always do everything together
and i was like oh i miss hallie like
nothing's going to be funny without her
like what am i going to do so so yeah i
think it's definitely helped me find my
inner confidence not only as an actress
but as a human being because i've kind
of had to like trust myself francia
raisa currently stars and how i met your
father another perk of being part of the
grownish cast i think i back before
const concerts came back but i wanted to
go a little concert and chloe was like
oh lizza watches grownu she knows who
you are i said what yeah as for yara
like hallie she also has a live-action
disney film coming out she stars as
tinker bell in peter pan and wendy we
keep clips of everybody's career forever
and everything you ever said i want to
give you this little clip to check out
oh god
y'all can check it out together i want
to become a historian
because i want to own a bookstore so i
can just walk in choose the books i'm
going to read and then walk out without
paying
when i'm done put it back and then i
still want to act
oh my gosh
is consistent
that hasn't changed
what do you look back right now if you
had that little girl sitting next to you
what would you say to her i mean i think
keep doing what you're doing i one thing
that my mother always says that is
applied to so much of what i've done is
like there's nothing more interesting
than an interested human and the fact
that i've been able to
go through this kind of i don't know do
you call it a career 21 um but if they
go through
go through this career and still have
the space to be interested in other
things has been such a privilege
[Music]
you